What if your brain could learn from its own activity? Not through talking, not through medication, but through real-time feedback about what it's actually doing. It sounds futuristic, but it's a technique called neurofeedback, and it's already being used to support people experiencing difficulties with anxiety, attention, trauma, sleep and more. In this episode, counselling psychologist and IALF neurofeedback practitioner, Dr Madeline Rhonetree, joins me as we explore what neurofeedback actually is, what the evidence says, and whether in future it could play a bigger role in mental health care and treatment. Hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to Psychology Actually. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist
如果你的大脑能够从自身的活动中学习会怎样？不是通过交谈，不是通过药物，而是通过关于它实际在做什么的实时反馈。这听起来很前卫，但这种技术被称为神经反馈，它已经被用于帮助那些在焦虑、注意力、创伤、睡眠等方面遇到困难的人。在本期节目中，咨询心理学家兼IALF神经反馈从业者Madeline Rhonetree博士将与我一起探讨什么是神经反馈，证据怎么说，以及它在未来是否能在心理健康护理和治疗中发挥更大的作用。希望你觉得这很有用。你好，欢迎来到《心理学实际上》（Psychology Actually）。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。
and today I am joined by Dr Madeline Rohn Tree, a qualified counselling psychologist. Hi, Madeline. Hi. Hi. So, pleased to have you here and I'm so excited. as well because today we're talking about something called neurofeedback, which is something that not that many people have heard of unless they have read the Bethel van der Kolk, The Body Keeps the Scorebook, which is where both you and I first heard about this from. I feel like it's the one that got away for me and it's the pandemic that got in the way of my
今天和我在一起的是Madeline Rohn Tree博士，她是一位合格的咨询心理学家。你好，Madeline。你好。你好。很高兴你能来，我也非常兴奋，因为今天我们要谈论的是一种叫做神经反馈的东西，除非读过贝塞尔·范德考克（Bessel van der Kolk）的《身体从未忘记》（The Body Keeps the Score）这本书，否则没多少人听说过它，我和你都是从这本书里第一次听说它的。我觉得这是我错失的机会，是疫情阻碍了我的
training, but you have done it. You are a neurofeedback practitioner. Could you tell our audience what neurofeedback is? So neurofeedback is a type of biofeedback. So you might have FitBits or your aura ring that's picking up your temperature, your heart rate. Neurofeedback is picking up signals from your brain and feeding that back to you. So you have, it's almost subconsciously really
培训，但你做到了。你是一位神经反馈从业者。你能告诉我们的听众什么是神经反馈吗？神经反馈是一种生物反馈。你可能用过Fitbit或Oura戒指，它们会记录你的体温、心率。神经反馈则是从你的大脑中获取信号，并将其反馈给你。所以你拥有它，这实际上几乎是潜意识的，
because your brain is feeding back rather than your sort of conscious self. But it's really a sensory feedback on the brain waves that are going through your mind. Amazing. And why does that matter and how does that help? Yeah, it's a really good question. So if we think about when we, we obviously wake and sleep, we have different states of alertness.
因为是你的大脑在反馈，而不是你的意识层面。但这确实是对你大脑中脑电波的一种感官反馈。太神奇了。这为什么重要，它又是如何提供帮助的呢？是的，这是一个非常好的问题。如果我们想想我们清醒和睡眠的时候，我们有不同的警觉状态。
And so in an ideal world, we want to be alert but not hypervigilant. We want to be relaxed but not disengaged or overly tense and emotionally responsible. are all responsive, so we're not sort of shut down. And in order to be in these states, we have different brain waves. So there's different frequencies for different brain waves that, sort of when we're awake, for example, we might have theta waves, sort of just daydreaming and hanging out in our heads. When we're sleeping, we have predominantly delta brainwaves. When we are sort of focused, we have beta, and they have like different frequencies. So the These are the different waves that kind of go through our brains and different states of wakefulness, if you will.
在理想情况下，我们希望保持警觉但不过度警惕。我们希望放松但不是脱节或过度紧张，并且在情绪上是有反应的，这样我们就不会处于“关闭”状态。为了处于这些状态，我们有不同的脑电波。不同的脑电波有不同的频率，比如当我们清醒时，我们可能有θ波，就像在脑子里做白日梦和闲逛一样。当我们睡觉时，我们主要是δ脑电波。当我们专注时，我们有β波，它们有不同的频率。所以这些就是当我们处于不同清醒状态时，穿过我们大脑的不同波。
When we're particularly anxious and stressed out, we might have high beta waves. So these are what we call frequency bands, if you will, with these different frequencies. So that kind of sort of tells us whether we're awake or asleep in broad terms. underneath these bands is an infra-low frequency. It's a really slow frequency that is almost like the tidal wave, if you will, sort of how the undulations of the tide is, as opposed to each wave, which might be the bands. When we think about the optimal state of being, we want to be alert, we want to be awake, we're not only hyper-vigilant, we want to have this sort of present, relaxed state, but ready to spring and into action, if we need to be. And our nervous system is the driving system, if you will, of all of that.
当我们特别焦虑和压力大时，我们可能会有高β波。这些就是我们所说的频段。从广义上讲，这告诉我们是清醒还是睡眠。在这些频段之下是超低频。这是一种非常缓慢的频率，就像潮汐一样，与可能代表频段的每一个波浪不同。当我们考虑最佳存在状态时，我们希望保持警觉，我们希望清醒，不仅是不过度警惕，我们还希望拥有这种当下的、放松的状态，但如果需要的话，随时准备行动。而我们的神经系统就是这一切的驱动系统。
So whether we are just sort of chilling out and having a cup of tea, but not so chill that if there's something that we need to attend to like an emergency, that we're not disengaged from that. We don't want to be so vigilant that we can't relax either. Our nervous system is the system that regulates all of that. And so if our nervous system is out of sync, we will be stuck in different brain states. And so if our brain can have a feedback information about how it's doing, it can better regulate itself. So I don't know if you've done any dancing or yoga or I don't even going to the gym. Generally, you'll see there's always mirrors, right? There's mirrors everywhere in these sorts of scenarios. Why? So that you can get feedback on your movements. Am I doing this
所以，无论我们是放松地喝杯茶，还是在需要处理紧急情况时保持专注，我们都不会与现实脱节。我们也不希望过度警惕以至于无法放松。我们的神经系统就是调节这一切的系统。因此，如果我们的神经系统不同步，我们就会被困在不同的脑状态中。如果大脑能得到关于它自身运作情况的反馈信息，它就能更好地自我调节。我不知道你是否跳过舞、练过瑜伽，甚至去过健身房。通常，你会发现到处都有镜子，对吧？在这些场景中到处都是镜子。为什么？这样你就能得到关于你动作的反馈。我做这个
movement correctly, am I stretching properly? Because if you don't get the feedback, how are you supposed to know to correct yourself? And this is exactly the same. So you're feeding back to your brain, its own brain waves, so that it can regulate itself. We have this propensity to fix, to get into equilibrium, to get back into harmony, back into sync because we want to operate functionally optimally. There's no good being stuck in any of these systems. So if our brains can get some information about how it's doing, it can then change that. That's so interesting. And yeah, it's reminded me of the Seben Fisher book I read on neurofeedback.
动作正确吗，我拉伸得对吗？因为如果你得不到反馈，你怎么知道如何纠正自己呢？这完全是一样的。你是在向大脑反馈它自己的脑电波，以便它能自我调节。我们有一种倾向，去修复，去进入平衡，回到和谐，回到同步，因为我们希望功能性地、最佳地运作。被困在任何这些系统中都不是好事。所以如果大脑能得到一些关于它运作情况的信息，它就能改变它。太有趣了。这让我想起了我读过的关于神经反馈的Seben Fisher的书。
And I just found it also fascinating. And I think I'm right in saying that she was talking about different brain waves. So, you know, delta, beta, theta, that kind of thing. And also made me think that I'm speaking to you at the moment with a broken hand, which I did watch happen via a mirror. I was at the gym when I did it. But can we have a little bit of a look at what might have been going on with my brain since then? So I did this on a Tuesday and today is the following Monday, so almost a week later.
我也觉得它非常迷人。我想我没记错的话，她谈到了不同的脑电波。你知道，δ、β、θ之类的。这也让我想起，我现在正带着一只骨折的手和你说话，我是在健身房时通过镜子看着它发生的。但我们能稍微看看从那时起我的大脑可能发生了什么吗？我是周二弄伤的，今天是下周一，也就是差不多一周后。
I have noticed that I am just more exhausted and I've got less bandwidth for things. I've had to kind of reprioritize things. Can we make sense of what's been going on with my brain since that trauma and since the pain? Yeah, absolutely. So I would say that to look at this through a neurofeedback lens, we can see that our nervous systems get impacted by stress. So a physical trauma will be stressful. The pain will presumably affect your sleep, which will then also affect your nervous system and how it operates. And so then we can see how the nervous system kind of gets out of sync, gets out of kilter. sometimes it's difficult to get back. So if your nervous system was a little bit more sticky, say, it will take time for it to get back to equilibrium. But that's what healing is. Healing is we have this natural propensity to want to heal and get back to equilibrium. And so your body is obviously producing extra red blood cells and white blood cells to kind of fix the trauma in your hand.
我注意到我只是更疲惫了，处理事情的带宽也变少了。我不得不重新安排事情的优先级。我们能理解自从那次创伤和疼痛以来我的大脑发生了什么吗？是的，绝对可以。我想通过神经反馈的视角来看，我们可以看到我们的神经系统会受到压力的影响。身体创伤会带来压力。疼痛可能会影响你的睡眠，这进而会影响你的神经系统及其运作方式。因此，我们可以看到神经系统是如何变得不同步、失调的。有时很难恢复。所以如果你的神经系统稍微“粘滞”一点，它需要时间才能恢复平衡。但这就是治愈。治愈意味着我们有一种自然的倾向，想要治愈并回到平衡。所以你的身体显然正在产生额外的红细胞和白细胞来修复你手上的创伤。
the pain is there to kind of tell you what not to do, right? Don't over, don't overwork it, so otherwise I can't heal. So all of that is working perfectly, but it's also taking from your bandwidth. I suppose as long as it's within a window of what you might call reasonable, yeah, it's reasonable to imagine that you're feeling a little bit tired and a little bit exhausted and maybe a bit frustrated because you can't do the things that you want to do and you have to rearrange stuff, then you would sort of think about, I guess,
疼痛的存在是为了告诉你不要做什么，对吧？不要过度使用它，否则它无法愈合。所以这一切都在完美地运作，但它也占用了你的带宽。我想只要它在所谓的合理范围内，想象一下你感到有点累、有点精疲力竭，也许因为不能做你想做的事而感到有点沮丧，不得不重新安排事情，这是合理的。
I guess we could maybe use the window of tolerance type of analogy here, right? That is this is to be expected. This is understandable. But let's say maybe three weeks later, you're still feeling this and you're still not able to, and there's still frustration. Well, maybe we could then start thinking about maybe the nervous system is stuck in some ways, that it needs to be re-regulated. And so from a neurofeedback perspective, it can actually help with pain.
我想我们也许可以在这里使用“耐受窗口”之类的类比，对吧？这是可以预料到的。这是可以理解的。但假设三周后，你仍然有这种感觉，仍然无法做到，并且仍然感到沮丧。好吧，也许我们就可以开始考虑神经系统在某些方面被困住了，它需要被重新调节。所以从神经反馈的角度来看，它实际上可以帮助缓解疼痛。
It can help with feeling a sense of calm. so that and reduce the stress the stress mechanisms that are associated with maybe being tense and in discomfort so interesting thank you i will keep a mindful watch on that i think it's going to be fine i'm already in less pain so i think it's going to be fine and generally speaking what sort of presentations can neurofeedback help people to achieve changes in the interesting thing i think with neurofeedback and so what i work with is is is infralow neurofeedback, which is slightly different to the band, the bands that you were talking about, the alpha-delta theta. So those are EEG bands that you can work on.
它可以帮助产生一种平静感，从而减少与紧张和不适相关的压力机制。太有趣了，谢谢。我会对此保持关注，我想我会没事的，我的疼痛已经减轻了，所以我认为会好起来的。总的来说，神经反馈可以帮助人们在哪些方面实现改变？我认为神经反馈有趣的地方在于，我所使用的是超低频神经反馈，这与你谈到的频段（α、δ、θ）略有不同。那些是可以处理的脑电图频段。
I work on the lower frequency, the infra-low frequency neurofeedback, which is that sort of the wave, this slow kind of, it's almost like the foundation. We sort of talk about the architecture of your nervous system in a way. So once you regulate that and get that where the arousal system is, let's call it in balance, the instabilities are also balanced out, then it makes sense to add the other band trainings on top of that. So what that means is that we address a broad range of experiences and don't really focus on diagnostics. So if we were to use diagnostics, say depression or anxiety, those are the sorts of things that neurofeedback can help with. So autism, ADHD, post-traumatic stress disorder, sleep issues, migraines and headaches,
我处理的是更低的频率，即超低频神经反馈，那是一种波，这种缓慢的频率，它几乎就像基础。我们谈论的是你神经系统的架构。一旦你调节了它，让唤醒系统处于平衡状态，不稳定性也会被平衡掉，那么在上面增加其他频段的训练才有意义。这意味着我们解决的是广泛的体验，而不真正关注诊断。如果我们使用诊断，比如抑郁或焦虑，这些都是神经反馈可以帮助解决的问题。所以自闭症、多动症（ADHD）、创伤后应激障碍、睡眠问题、偏头痛和头痛、
ticks, vertigo, perimenopausal symptoms. So it's, it can, it's because there's downstream effects of regulating a whole network. And so then it's an interesting way of working because when I talk, when I work with clients, we have this, it's 150 symptom checklist of all of the things that you might experience. You rate them on a scale from 1 to 10, like how, how am I much am I marked by various? And you go through psychological, sort of, so, it's like sort of the, well, just everything really you can think of from sleep issues to your appetite to everything. And so then you focus on, because that's the way we work around, then you focus on the ones that are scoring the highest,
抽动症、眩晕、围绝经期症状。因为调节整个网络会有下游效应。所以这是一种有趣的工作方式，因为当我与客户交谈时，我们有一个150项的症状清单，列出了你可能经历的所有事情。你按1到10的等级对它们进行评分，看看你受各种症状的影响有多大。你经历心理层面的，所以，这就像是，嗯，你能想到的所有事情，从睡眠问题到食欲，应有尽有。然后你专注于那些得分最高的，
because these are the things that are going to be sort of impacted by the most. So it could look like the variability is huge. So I could have sleep issues, food difficulties, mood issues, and distractibility. So it's like a variety of things, which doesn't really necessarily fall under a particular diagnostic. Yet with the neurofeedback, we're having some ideas around, okay, this is, this might be an issue with instability, say, there's instability in my system, that I, my system struggles to toggle easily back and forwards to get to equilibrium, or it could be an arousal issue, that I have too much of something or too little of something. So I might have, if I have an overall,
因为这些是受影响最大的。所以它看起来可能变异性很大。我可能有睡眠问题、饮食困难、情绪问题和注意力不集中。所以这是各种各样的事情，并不一定属于特定的诊断。然而通过神经反馈，我们对以下情况有一些想法：好吧，这可能是一个不稳定性问题，比如我的系统存在不稳定性，我的系统难以轻松地来回切换以达到平衡，或者它可能是一个唤醒问题，即我有太多的某种东西或太少的某种东西。所以如果我有一个整体的
arousal system, then it's anxiety, panic attacks, you know, those sorts of things, sort of insomnia, racing thoughts, that's sort of an over arousal. So then I'm having some ideas around, okay, what is it that the nervous system needs? It needs to have a sort of a karma. Well, it could be under arousal. So you have low mood, lethargy, fatigue, brain fog, these sorts of things. So that's a low arousal. And so it's kind of like an arousal and instability question. that we target from an ILF, you're a feedback perspective, the downstream effects of that is these huge, sort of broad range of difficulties, I guess, that people experience.
唤醒系统，那么它就是焦虑、恐慌发作，你知道，诸如此类的事情，失眠、思绪飞转，那是一种过度唤醒。所以我对神经系统需要什么有一些想法。它需要一种平静。好吧，它也可能是唤醒不足。所以你有低落的情绪、嗜睡、疲劳、脑雾，这些东西。所以那是低唤醒。因此，这有点像是一个唤醒和不稳定性问题，我们从ILF神经反馈的角度来针对它，其下游效应就是人们经历的这些巨大的、广泛的困难。
I see. So with, I know when I was reading the literature, it's about, you know, for example, complex trauma. And you've got an over-arousal because the body and the mind is constantly trying to work out why it's not safe or to feel safe or to kind of manipulate that environment. and they might be more anxious, they might be lower in mood. And so how might you expect, I don't know, I don't know how many sessions you typically have for somebody
我明白了。我知道当我阅读文献时，它是关于，例如，复杂性创伤。你有一种过度唤醒，因为身体和大脑不断地试图弄清楚为什么它不安全，或者试图感到安全，或者试图操纵那个环境。他们可能更焦虑，情绪可能更低落。那么你可能会预期，我不知道，我不知道你通常为某人进行多少次疗程
with a complex trauma background, but how might that person's presentation change over time if they were treated with neurofeedback? So with PTSD, for example, you would, this is the thing, that's a diagnostic. So from a neurofeedback perspective, you would kind of like ask other questions you'd want to have sort of more back, I suppose you'd do this anyway within trauma work, right?
有复杂创伤背景的人，但如果他们接受神经反馈治疗，那个人的表现会随时间发生怎样的变化？以创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）为例，这就是问题所在，那是一个诊断。所以从神经反馈的角度来看，你会问其他问题，你会想要有更多的背景，我想你在创伤工作中无论如何都会这样做，对吧？
You'd want to have a full, the whole biopsychosocial kind of that template to ask about. But you'd also ask specifically which, I suppose, let me show you, I've got, you have sensors. I'm going to deviate slightly. You have sensors that you, that will pick up that you put on different places. So with infralow frequency, you have, sensors that you sort of place, but two of them always get placed in different way places depending on what it is that you want to work with. So you'd ask a whole bunch of questions in terms of figuring out where to start. Is it instability? Do I want
你会想要有一个完整的、整个生物心理社会模板来询问。但你也会专门询问，我想，让我给你展示一下，我有，你有传感器。我会稍微偏离一下。你有传感器，你会把它们放在不同的地方。对于超低频，你有传感器，你放置它们，但其中两个总是根据你想处理的内容放置在不同的地方。所以你会问一大堆问题来弄清楚从哪里开始。是不稳定性吗？我想
to stabilize the system? So headaches, seizures, flashbacks, dissociation is an instability issue, say. If for example somebody with PTSD has flashbacks, this would what we call a T3-T4 instability issue. So I put a placement on my, just above my ears on the left and the right hand side. If it's more sort of anxiety and panic, that's an intrusive thought, say, then I would want to lower the arousal where then I'd put the placements at the back on the right hand side and just above the right ear. So those are the two main placements that you would start to sort of stable. and regulate the nervous system. And so, again, it depends on what the client is coming with in terms of what is the most significant difficulty
稳定系统吗？所以头痛、癫痫发作、闪回、解离都是不稳定性问题。例如，如果患有PTSD的人有闪回，这就是我们所说的T3-T4不稳定性问题。所以我把传感器放在我耳朵上方，左侧和右侧。如果是更多的焦虑和恐慌，那是侵入性思维，那么我会想要降低唤醒水平，我会把传感器放在右侧后方和右耳上方。所以这些是你开始稳定和调节神经系统的两个主要放置位置。同样，这取决于客户带来的最显著的困难
or experience that they are they're having. I suppose the thing with diagnostics is it kind of gives you an rough idea about where in the department store that you're going to go shopping in a way, right? If it's depression, it's more likely to be low arousal, brainfrog, low motivation. So then you have some ideas about the people.
或经历。我想诊断的问题在于，它在某种程度上给了你一个关于你要去百货公司的哪个部门购物的大致概念，对吧？如果是抑郁症，它更有可能是低唤醒、脑雾、低动力。所以你对人们有一些想法。
protocols where you want to place them. If it's anxiety, you want to figure out, is it a rumination overthinking OCD-like, or is it more sort of visceral kind of in the body, sort of panic of versions? So again, it will just kind of tell you whether you want to, is it instability or an arousal question. I see. And so these are electrodes that get placed actually onto the scalp or the forehead. And I think, right in saying that you kind of almost like playing games. So I think I remember there was one case where you've got two rockets and you need to kind of think, think the rockets taking off. Is that right? How does it work?
协议，你想把它们放在哪里。如果是焦虑，你想弄清楚，是反刍、过度思考、强迫症式的，还是更偏向于身体上的、内脏的、恐慌发作？所以同样，它只会告诉你你是想要处理不稳定性还是唤醒问题。我明白了。所以这些是实际放置在头皮或前额上的电极。我想我没记错的话，你们几乎就像在玩游戏。我想我记得有一个案例，你有两个火箭，你需要思考，思考火箭起飞。是这样吗？它是如何工作的？
So those are the band frequency. So the C-Bahn book doesn't talk about INF and neurofeedback. So the band frequency, so the typical ones that you would train are alpha, alpha- theta, or alpha-beater. they might they wait they can work on operant conditioning so you have some kind of a reward so like a rocket that that sort of takes off what have you with infralow frequency the frequency so slow it's it's there's no kind of reward for the brain necessarily and so what you what the feedback looks like depending on the program that you're using it could be well there's three ways of getting the feedback. So visually, so you might be looking at a screen. And the screen, depending on what you're using, I mean, you could use, for example, a YouTube, so you can
那些是频段频率。所以C-Bahn的书没有谈论INF和神经反馈。所以频段频率，你通常训练的是α、α-θ或α-β。它们可以使用操作性条件反射，所以你有一些奖励，比如一个起飞的火箭之类的。对于超低频，频率太慢了，大脑不一定有奖励。所以反馈看起来是什么样的，取决于你使用的程序，有三种获得反馈的方式。视觉上，你可能在看屏幕。屏幕，取决于你使用的东西，我的意思是，你可以使用，例如，YouTube，所以你可以
add YouTube onto the system and then it would increase or decrease in size, for example. So that, what would you call that? Sort of the frequency by which it decreases and increases is kind of like a pulse, I suppose, and that pulse is letting the brain know that this is what your, your, your frequency is doing. This is what your brain is doing at these particular electrode placements. Now, nothing's going into the brain. A lot of people worry about something's happening to them because they sound like, you know, electrodes sound quite. So I call them sensors because that's all they're doing. They're just picking up information and then giving it back to you, a bit like an aura ring or a refit bit. Nothing's happening to you. All it is is your brain kind of
将YouTube添加到系统中，然后它会变大或变小。所以，你会称那为什么？它减小和增加的频率有点像脉冲，我想，那个脉冲让大脑知道这就是你的频率在做的事情。这就是你的大脑在这些特定电极位置所做的事情。现在，没有什么东西进入大脑。很多人担心有什么事情发生在他们身上，因为听起来，你知道，电极听起来相当……所以我称它们为传感器，因为这就是它们所做的。它们只是获取信息然后反馈给你，有点像Oura戒指或Fitbit。没有什么事情发生在你的身上。它只是你的大脑意识到这个正在显示的模式是我的。所以我想一个例子可以是，你和我可能在社交活动中交谈，然后你听到你的名字，你会转过身，你会对那个做出反应。你不是在和我说话时特意听你的名字被叫到。你的大脑在做那个。我们的大脑一直在扫描模式。如果我要说“玛丽，玛丽有一只小……”，你的大脑会立刻想到“羔羊”，对吧？因为那是它学到的模式。所以我们的大脑一直在寻找模式。现在你看着这个屏幕，你戴着耳机。所以你也在获得听觉信息。我还有触觉的。它就像一个小盒子，会振动。所以我有了三种
realizing that this pattern that is being shown to me is mine. So I think an example could be you and I might have a conversation, you know, in a networking event, and then you hear your name and you'll sort of turn, you'll react to that. You're not talking to me listening purposely out for your name being called. Your brain is doing that. Our brains scan for patterns the whole time. If I was to say Mary Mary had a little, your brain is instantly going to go lamb, right? Because that's the pattern it's learned. So our brains are constantly looking for patterns. So now you're looking at this screen and you have headphones on. So you're also getting auditory information. And I also have a tactile ones. It's like a little box that sort of vibrates. So I've got three
我的大脑可以用来给我反馈其节奏的方法。所以这就是它在做的。它注意到这些模式并想，哦天哪，这是我，这是我。然后，等等，这感觉不太好。然后它就自我调节了。它真的很聪明。是的，确实。而且这几乎让人难以理解，不是吗？就像，如果有人从未听说过这个。它是非常被动的。作为治疗师，你问问题，你注意到脸部的微动作，你倾听那些没说出来的话，你非常主动。但在这里，你只是在看一些东西，听一些东西。然后作为从业者，我问我的客户，身体感觉如何？
methods by which my brain can then give me feedback on its rhythms. And so that's what it's doing. It's noticing these patterns and thinking, oh gosh, this is me, this is me. And then, I mean, hang on a second, this doesn't feel really nice. And so then it regulates itself. It's really clever. Yeah, it is. And it's also a lot to almost get your head around as well, isn't it? Like, if someone's never heard of this. It's very passive. As a therapist, you're asking questions and you're noticing micro-movements in the face and you're kind of like listening out for stuff that's not said and you're sort of really active. But here, you're just watching something and listening to something. And And then as a practitioner, I'm sort of asking my clients, so how does it feel on the body?
你感觉怎么样？并利用他们的反馈来告知我我们是否走在正确的轨道上。大家好，是我。我插播一下，告诉你们一些令人兴奋的消息，因为我真的认为关于神经反馈的对话早就该进行了。如果像我一样，你对神经反馈如何改变心理健康着迷，那么你正在收听正确的对话。拍摄结束后，我联系了B-Medic，我很高兴地说，他们不仅赞助了这一集，还为你提供了一个独家折扣码。如果你想为你的客户带来ILF神经反馈的好处，那么B-Medic提供完整的医疗系统和认证培训来支持你的旅程。作为全球心理健康专家医疗设备和配件的供应商，
How are you feeling? And kind of using their feedback to inform me on whether we're on the right track or not. Hi there, only me. I'm just popping in here to let you have some exciting news because I really do believe that conversations about neurofeedback are so long overdue. If like me, you're fascinated by how neurofeedback can transform mental health, then you are listening to the right conversation. After filming finished, I contacted B-Medic and I'm delighted to say, not only are they sponsoring this episode, they're also offering you an exclusive discount code. If you'd like to bring the benefits of ILF neurofeedback to your clients, then B-Medic offers complete medical systems and accredited training to support your journey. As a global supplier of medical equipment and accessories for mental health specialists,
B-Medic提供可靠、高质量和模块化的系统。让你从小规模开始，只购买你需要的东西，然后随时扩展。如果你是一位心理健康专业人士，希望通过这种循证方法提升你的实践，那么B-Medic在英国和国际上都提供基础认证课程。他们的现场课程甚至为你提供宝贵的CPD学分，为你提供实用的技能、技术支持和临床监督培训，让你立即开始。通过访问他们的网站B-Medic.com发现他们即将开设的课程日期和技术。
B-Medic offers reliable, high-quality and modular systems. allowing you to start small, acquiring only what you need and then expanding at any time. If you're a mental health professional looking to elevate your practice with this evidence-based method, then B-Medic offers basic accredited courses all over the UK and internationally too. Their on-site courses even offer you valuable CPD points, giving you the practical skills, technical support, and clinically supervised training to get started right away. Discover their upcoming course dates and technologies by visiting their website, B-Medic.com.
那是www.B-E-E-M-E-D-I-C.com。或者点击我节目说明中的链接。你还可以使用我的独家代码“actually20”节省20%，A-C-T-U-A-L-L-Y-20。这在2026年英国的所有基础课程中都有效，快点，因为代码有效期至2026年11月1日。现在让我们回到我和Madeline博士的聊天，这样你就可以更深入地爱上ILF神经反馈。
That's www. B-E-E-M-E-D-I-C.com. Or click the link in my show notes. And you can also save 20% with my exclusive code, actually 20, A-C-T-U-A-L-L-Y-20. And that is valid on all basic courses in the UK during 20. 2026, hurry because the code is valid until the 1st of November, 2026. Now let's get back to my chat with Dr Madeline so you can fall even deeper in love with ILF neurofeedback.
好的，例如，自闭症患者，患有ADHD诊断的人，他们可能会看到什么样的变化，我们做出这些改变或帮助人们做出这些改变可以吗？所以，当然，从我过去工作的社会精神病学来看，我们总是讨论症状是否令人困扰。例子就是强迫症。假设我有强迫症，我每天早上出门前检查五次门把手。现在这困扰我吗？
Okay, so for example, autistic people, people with an ADHD diagnosis, what kind of changes might they see and is it okay that we're making those changes or helping people to make those changes? So, certainly from social psychiatry back in the day when I worked in that, we always talked about whether symptoms were bothersome. So the example would be OCD, for example. So let's say I have OCD and I checked my door handle five times every morning before I leave. Now does that bother me?
不。这是一个问题吗？不。我需要为此接受治疗吗？不。或者，正如我的CBT培训师曾经说过的，你知道，我知道我压力大时，如果我丈夫没把杯子放进洗碗机，我会非常生气。那么我想为此接受治疗吗？不，因为我知道这是怎么回事。所以这有点像同样的事情。就像，你被这些事情困扰吗？
No. Is it an issue? No. Do I need to have therapy for it? No. Or, as my CBT trainer once said, you know, I know when I'm stressed, I'm going to be really pissed off it for my husband, hasn't put his cup away in the dishwasher. So do I want to have therapy about that? No, because I know what it's all about. So it's kind of like the same sort of thing. Like, are you bothered by these things?
比如我的儿子，他七岁。学校报告说，他听不进去。他很容易分心。总是和别的朋友玩，他不……而且这对我们来说并不罕见，不是什么大新闻，因为这是第无数次了，你能做X吗？即使在游泳时，你也会看到他做各种其他事情，而不是听教练的话。所以显然是一个注意力不集中的问题。所以我试着在他假期里对他进行超低频神经反馈，你总是会想，这是神经反馈还是安慰剂？这只是因为我们在做这个吗？你知道，我对我的
So my son, for example, he's seven. And school reports came back with, you know, he doesn't listen. He's easily distractible. keeps playing with his other friends and he doesn't you know and this is not unusual for us no big news for us because it's like for the umpteenth time can you do X and even in swimming you'd see him like doing all sorts of other things rather than listening to the instructor so clearly an inattention issue and so I tried the infralone neurofeedback on him in in a half term and you're always sort of is it neurofeedback or is it placebo? Like is it just because we are doing this? You know, and I said to my
丈夫说，如果学校认可了什么，那才是真正的证明。果然，我想两周后我们有一个家长会。老师非常自发地说，这真的很有趣。自假期以来，他一直表现得很好。你就像，好吧，没问题，你知道，我真的很好奇，像我这样的科学家，我就像……因为他们有这些追踪系统，你知道，如果他们表现不好或做了什么，他们就会被记录，有一个警告系统。我说，那么，她去，他说他整周都没有被记录。我说，哦，那假期前他多久会被记录一次？
husband, well, the proof will be in the pudding if the school recognises anything. And sure enough, I think two weeks later we have, you know, a parent meeting. And the teacher goes quite spontaneously, it's really interesting. Since the half term, he's been so good. And you're just like, well, okay, fine, you know, and I was like really curious like me, the scientist and me was kind of like So, because they have these tracker systems, you know, if they misbehave or do something, they go on track her and there's a warning system. And I'm like, so, and she goes, she hasn't been on tracker, he hasn't been on tracker all week. And I'm like, oh, so how often would be on tracker before half term?
她说，哦，大约每周四五次。现在我说，她说，哦，或者可能一两次。我说，好吧，我们有硬数据表明有些事情正在改变。这在某种程度上就像盲控，因为她不知道。我们一直在做什么。所以你可以说，如果你在寻找危险，分心是好的，但如果你在学校环境中需要集中注意力听老师讲课，那么这显然不是一个真正高效的位置。
And she goes, oh, about four or five times a week. And now I go, she goes, oh, or maybe once or twice. I'm like, okay, right, we've got hard data here that suggests there's something that's changing. And it's kind of like blind control in a way because she doesn't know. what we've been doing. So you could say, well, it's good to be distractible if you're, you know, looking out for danger, say, but if you're in a school environment and need to concentrate and listen to what the teacher's saying, well, then that's obviously not a really productive position to be in.
而且加上这个可怜的孩子，对吧，他被责骂的次数减少了80%，真的，对吧？所以学校现在将是一个更美好的体验。在家里，你知道，现在是，你能准备好上学吗？他手里拿着自己做的三明治，衣服、书包准备好了，鞋子也穿好了。我说，你是谁？就像，你是谁？对吧？
And plus the poor kid, right, he's getting an 80% reduction in being told off, really, right? So school is now going to be a much nicer experience. And at home, you know, it's now, can you get ready for school? and he's sandwich in hand that he's made by himself with clothing and book bag ready and shoes. And I'm like, who are you? Like, who are you? Right?
所以巨大的变化。这真的很令人印象深刻。是的，听起来是这样。我想我自己也可以尝试一下。我想我丈夫也会希望我这样做。是的。有大量的新兴证据基础吗？所以当然，当我在NHS时，我说，
So massive changes. It's really impressive. Yeah, it sounds it. I think I could go on that for myself. I think my husband would like me to do it as well. Yeah. Is there much emerging evidence base? So of course, when I was in the NHS, I said,
哦，我们可以，你知道，你能付钱让我接受这方面的培训吗？他们说，不。所以我打算自费。但有什么新兴的东西吗？它最终会进入NICE指南吗？你能想象吗？绝对，绝对。我认为它正朝着那个方向发展。
oh, can we, you know, can you pay for me to be trained in this? And they were like, no. So I was going to be self-funding. But is there any emerging stuff? Is it ever going to end up on the nice guidance? Could you imagine? Definitely, definitely. I think it's headed in that direction.
2022年发表了一项大规模的研究，文献综述，他们发现了18项他们可以使用的研究，基本上，在他们确定的36或40项关于超低频神经反馈的工作中。但他们也证明了自过去20年以来，该领域的研究呈指数级增长。我的意思是，神经反馈已经存在很长时间了。超低频存在的时间较短。
There was a massive study, a literature review that came out in 2022, that found, they found 18 studies that they could use, basically, out of, I think, 36 or about 40 pieces of work that they had identified as for or infrared low neurofeedback specifically. But they'd also demonstrated an almost an exponential growth in research around the area since, I think, the last 20 years. I mean, neurofeedback has been around for a very long time. Infra low has been around for a shorter amount of time.
所以主动治疗组，我想他们的范围，嗯，很多研究是单案例研究。我想一两项研究可能有40名参与者。也许其中一半是对照组。所以主要的批评是我们没有足够大的对照组。我认为另一个困难是它非常个性化。你知道，我们的神经系统是不同的，取决于你在什么环境中长大，什么，你知道，你刚刚弄伤了手，所以也许你的神经系统有点失调。
So the active treatment group, I suppose they range, well, a lot of the studies are single case studies. And I think one or two of the studies had maybe 40 participants in them. and maybe half of those were control groups. So the main criticism is we don't have big enough controls. Another difficulty, I think, is that it's very individualized. You know, our nervous systems are different, depending on what environment we've grown up and what, you know, you've just broken your hands, say, so maybe your nervous system is out of kink a little bit.
所以它在放置位置方面非常个性化，无论是耳朵上方还是脑后。或者无论我们把这些传感器放在哪里，这使得在协议方面难以标准化，对吧？所以这些是它的主要批评。话虽如此，最近，我想是今年，有一项MFRI研究发表，单次ILF疗程后，单次疗程内就有神经学变化。所以肯定有很有希望的研究出来，更多的人正在，它正在，你知道，如果你考虑医学，即使在医学领域，一项发现进入医学院教给我们的全科医生或其他人，平均需要17年，对吧？
And so it's quite individualized in terms of the placements, whether it's, you know, over the ears or behind the head. or wherever we put these placements, which makes it difficult to standardize as terms of protocols, right? So those are the main criticisms of it. That said, there's just recently, I think it was this year that was an MFRI study published with single ILF sessions and neurological changes already in a single session. So there's definitely promising research that's coming out and more people are, it's having, you know, if you think about medicine, it takes decades for even in, I think, I think the average age in medical school for some finding in the medical field, it takes 17 years on average for it to reach medical school to be taught to our GPs or whoever, right?
所以，你知道，这在某种程度上是全新的东西，尽管它已经有几十年了，但它肯定正在获得关注。我所看到的改变有时会让我对自己说，为什么这没有更广泛地提供？我发现它具有变革性。在Madeline博士和我聊天后，我稍微深入研究了神经反馈的研究。我还联系了B-Medic，他们给了我更多相关研究的例子。我知道如果你是节目的粉丝，你也关心研究。所以自从Madeline博士和我聊天后，我更加深入地研究了证据基础。
So it's, it's, you know, this is a, in some, in one way it's the brand new thing, even though it's decades old, but it's definitely gaining traction. And the, the changes that I've seen is I sometimes tell myself, like why is this not more widely available? It's that transformative I find. Since Dr. Madeline and I chatted, I had a little dive into the research for neurofeedback. And I also got in contact with B-Medic, who gave me a few more examples of relevant research. I know that if you're a fan of the show, you also care about research. So since Dr. Madeline and I chatted, I have had a little look into the evidence base even more.
我也和B-Medic聊过了。神经反馈的神经生理学效应现在实际上已经汇集成了一个相当坚实的证据基础。还有具有里程碑意义的fMRI研究，发表在《Neuro Image》杂志上，研究了ILF神经反馈导致的大脑连接。所有这些细节都在节目说明和视频描述中。希望你也认为这真的很重要，并且让你更加兴奋。现在，回到Madeline博士和我的问题。它是治疗的一个如此美丽的补充。所以我开始认为神经反馈就像在处理硬件，而治疗处理软件。我们就像在更新我们的思想
And I've chatted with B-Medic as well. The neurophysiological effects of neurofeedback are actually now coming together as a pretty solid evidence base. There's also the landmark fMRI study, which was published in the journal Neuro Image and looking at the kind of connections in the brain as a result of ILF neurofeedback. All of the details for this are in the show notes and in the description for the video. Hope that you also think this really matters and it's making you even more excited. Now, back to Dr. Madeline and my question. It's such a beautiful bolt on to therapy. So I'm beginning to see this as sort of neurofeedback is like working on the hardware and therapy works on the software. We're like updating our thoughts
和我们的信念系统，但神经反馈只是在我们的治疗目标方面让我们越过了终点线。这真的很迷人。听起来它就像是触及了其他疗法无法触及的大脑部分和表现的治疗。是的，绝对，100%。关于，你知道，药物可能会有副作用，这有什么风险吗？这是一个好问题。所以是也不是。所以没有，它不是副作用。它只是训练神经系统的效果。所以如果你已经过度警惕，并且你的频率有点太高，你可能会加剧这种情况，或者你可能会有点头痛，因为它是神经
and our, you know, our belief systems, but the neurofeedback just gets us over the edge in terms of the finish line with our therapeutic goals. It's really fascinating. It's like the treatment that reaches parts of the brain and the presentation that other therapies. can't, it sounds like. Yeah, absolutely, 100%. And in terms of, you know, medication can have side effects, are there any risks to this? It's a good question. So yes and no. So there's no, it's not side effects as such. It's just the effect of training a system, nervous system. So if you, if you are already hypervigilance, say, and you have a frequency that's a bit too high, you might aggravate that or you might get a little bit of a headache because it's it's the nervous
系统有点“哦，我不喜欢这个”，所以它会反应，它会……这是它告诉你“我不喜欢我看到的，我需要你改变频率”的方式。不过它是短暂的，对吧？因为单次疗程可能持续长达48小时左右，类似这样的东西，你知道，这也是神经反馈在某些方面的缺点，我想，你需要相当多的疗程。建议至少进行20次疗程，每周至少一次，理想情况下每周两到三次，同样，取决于你的，比如，你反应有多好，或者你对反馈有多敏感。如果你有不良反应，它是短暂的，你也可以改变。所以假设如果我有一个客户在疗程中头痛，我可以改变放置位置，然后我就停止了头痛。我曾经有，你知道，几乎偏头痛，对吧，偏头痛发作，然后我们进去，我们的不稳定性在耳朵上方，对吧，左耳和右耳，然后偏头痛消失了，以至于，你知道，正如我所说，每次疗程后你都需要检查。所以在这里，我提前一点与这位客户检查，说，你知道，偏头痛怎么样了？他们说，哦，我完全忘记它了。
system is kind of oh i don't like this so it will react it will this is the way it's telling you i don't like i don't like what i'm seeing i need you i need you to change the frequency it's short-lived though right because a single session it maybe lasts up to about 48 hours or something something like this you know so which which is also the downside of neurofeedback in some ways i guess is you need quite a few sessions. The recommended is a minimum of 20 sessions at least once a week, ideally two to three times a week, again, depending on your, like, how well you respond or how sensitive you are to the feedback. If you have an adverse effect, it would be short-lived and you can also change. So let's say if I have a client that has, gets a headache in the
你知道，所以它真的可以。是的，我的意思是，这就是让我们在私信中谈论神经反馈的原因，因为我分享了我儿子有偏头痛，他九岁，他已经患有多年了，你说，你试过神经反馈吗？我说，嗯，不，我没有。然后你说，哦，我受过这方面的培训。所以是的，我想这方面的缺点是，因为它目前在NHS中并没有真正提供，所以如果你需要每周多次疗程，或者至少每周一次，成本可能会增加，不是吗？我发现我，作为一名私人从业者，在自己的治疗中，我，我想我不记得现在是哪家保险公司了，
session, I can just change the placement and then I stop the headache. I've had people, you know, almost migraine, right, onset migraine, and then we go in, our instabilities over the ears, right, the left and the right ear, and then migraine gone to the point where, you know, after, like I said, after every session you need to check in. And so here I am checking in a little bit earlier with this client saying, you know, how's the, how's the migraine? And they go, oh, I'd completely forgotten about it.
疗程中，我只需要改变一下位置，头痛就停止了。我遇到过那种几乎要偏头痛发作的人，我们介入处理耳朵两侧的不稳定性，然后偏头痛就消失了，以至于像我说的，每次疗程后都需要确认一下情况。所以我在这里提前一点询问这位客户，问他们偏头痛怎么样了，他们说，哦，我都完全忘了这回事了。
You know, so it can really. Yeah, I mean, that's what got us talking about neurofeedback in the DMs because I shared that my son has migraines and he's nine and he's had them for years and you're like, have you ever tried neurofeedback? And I was like, well, no, I haven't. And then you're like, oh, I'm trained in it. So yeah, like I guess the disadvantage to this is, is that because it's not really available on the NHS currently is that if you're needing multiple sessions a week or certainly weekly, the cost can stack up, can't it? I have found that I, as a private practitioner, in own therapy, I have, I think I can't remember which insurance company it is now,
所以它确实可以。是的，这就是我们开始在私信里讨论神经反馈的原因，因为我分享了我九岁的儿子患有偏头痛，而且已经好几年了，你就问我，你试过神经反馈吗？我说，嗯，没有。然后你说，哦，我受过这方面的培训。所以是的，我想这方面的缺点是，因为它目前在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）中并不普及，如果你需要每周进行多次疗程，或者至少每周一次，费用确实会累积起来，不是吗？我发现作为一名私人执业治疗师，我，我想我不记得是哪家保险公司了，
but they have allowed neurofeedback simply because it was the last port of course. I had a particular patient where done loads of therapy, done all the medication, quote-unquote, none of it worked, let's try neurofeedback, and then the insurance company goes fine. And so something is happening in terms of the recognition of this. Okay. And obviously not to share any personal details of that client, but is that making progress? Is it making changes for that client?
但他们已经允许使用神经反馈，仅仅因为它成了最后的救命稻草。我曾有一位特殊的病人，做过大量的治疗，用过所有的药物，引用一下，但都没用。我们尝试了神经反馈，保险公司也就同意了。所以，在对这种疗法的认可方面，确实发生了一些变化。好的。显然，我不会透露该客户的任何个人细节，但这种疗法有进展吗？它为该客户带来了改变吗？
Yeah. I don't know if I can share. I don't think they would mind. There's an anger and difficulty almost coming in with a black eye from a road rage incident. And a few weeks later coming back into therapy, saying, oh, there was an incident, but I wasn't bothered. And that's, yeah, some of the literature I'd been reading was kind of using neurofeedback
是的。我不知道我是否可以分享。我想他们不会介意的。有一次，一位病人因为路怒事件导致眼睛淤青，带着愤怒和困难来到诊所。几周后，他回到治疗中说，哦，虽然发生了冲突，但我并没有感到困扰。这就是，是的，我读过的一些文献中提到使用神经反馈
post-traumatic brain injury and how you could really help the brain to repair itself in a way that just hasn't been possible with kind of rehab work. And it's just fascinating stuff. It really is fascinating. And, you know, when you, when you read this list of things that it can, it can it can help with your life oh oh and when when i did the training i'm like oh really night sweats i'm in sort of perimenopal state right like oh night sweats and disturbed sleep and brain fog um and it seriously does so so for me that so that's kind of i'm dyslexic so i and i think i'm neurospicy in the sense that you know tabs open and a little bit of distractibility i know my placements now if i'm feeling a little bit demotivated, a little bit flat. I've historically been prone to depression.
治疗创伤性脑损伤，以及它如何能真正帮助大脑以一种康复工作无法实现的方式进行自我修复。这真是太迷人了。确实非常迷人。而且，你知道，当你阅读它能帮助解决的问题清单时，哦，当我进行训练时，我想，哦，真的吗？盗汗？我正处于围绝经期，对吧？哦，盗汗、睡眠障碍和脑雾。它确实有效。所以对我来说，我是阅读障碍者，我认为我是神经多样性人群，你知道，标签页开得太多，有点注意力不集中。我现在知道我的放置位置了，如果我感到有点动力不足，有点情绪低落。我过去一直容易抑郁。
I put on my antidepressant placement and the next day it's I'm good again. It's nuts. It's almost again, I sometimes sort of is this is it is this placebo or is this kind of like it's but it does it does it does it does it does it does it does it does it you know is it is it an issue where is if let's say I can't I can't organize myself and I can't. I'm just inundated with sensory informational visual stimuli coming at me. Then I've obviously, my whole family, blessed them, have been through the whole neurofeedback treadmill. And my husband's like, well, I'm fine.
我戴上抗抑郁的放置位置，第二天我就感觉好多了。这太疯狂了。有时我也会想，这是安慰剂效应吗？还是别的什么？但它确实有效。你知道，如果说我无法组织自己，我被涌来的感官信息和视觉刺激淹没了。那么，显然，我的整个家庭，祝福他们，都经历过神经反馈的训练。我丈夫说，嗯，我很好。
I don't really need anything. Well, if there was anything, I could maybe do with a bit of, you know, good, better focus. Fine, right. So we train on that. And he's, I'm sure he doesn't mind me sharing the story. He, amongst other things, does printing. So printing press, so etching.
我真的不需要什么。嗯，如果非要说有什么，我可能需要一点，你知道，更好一点的专注力。好的，没问题。所以我们针对那个进行训练。我相信他不介意我分享这个故事。他除了做其他事情外，还从事印刷工作。也就是印刷机，蚀刻。
This is a very old technology, where you put pieces of paper through a press to print fine art. And so I guess it could be a slightly mundane job, right? And he said, oh, I lint straight into this. Normally I'd be like, right, when can I finish this job so I can get onto the next one? And he was like, I felt almost serene and calm doing this, which was a new experience for him. So that was quite interesting. So, yeah. How nice.
这是一种非常古老的技术，你把纸张放入印刷机来印刷艺术品。所以我想这可能是一份有点枯燥的工作，对吧？他说，哦，我直接投入其中了。通常我会想，好吧，我什么时候能做完这份工作，好去做下一份？而他当时感觉，做这件事时我感到一种宁静和平和，这对他来说是一种全新的体验。所以这非常有趣。所以，是的。多好啊。
my husband would say, can you keep the hall table clutter free? And can you keep your side of your side of the bedroom a little bit tidier? It's not awful, but yeah, like that's the recurrent themes from our marriage that he would change in a heartbeat. It's been so interesting chatting with you. And this hasn't done anything for dissuading me for learning more about this. So thank you. This really does feel like the one that got away. I was almost about to book onto training and then the pandemic unfolded and then I've gone online only.
我丈夫会说，你能保持玄关桌整洁吗？你能把你卧室那一侧收拾得整齐一点吗？虽然不至于很糟糕，但那是我们婚姻中他最想改变的反复出现的主题。和你聊天真有意思。这并没有打消我进一步了解它的念头。所以谢谢你。这真的感觉像是错失的机会。我本来差点就要报名参加培训了，然后疫情爆发了，我就转为纯线上工作了。
But thank you. Where can people learn more about you and your work, Madeline? So I've just started a clinic in London called the London Neurofeedback Clinic. So that's it, the London NeurofeedbackClick.com. It's based in East London. There is also a directory on the B-Medic.com website where you can find your feedback practitioners across the world. So if you're not in London, maybe take a look at them. They will be practitioners that do more than ILF as well, so they'll do frequency band training as well.
但谢谢你。人们可以在哪里了解更多关于你和你的工作，马德琳？我刚在伦敦开了一家诊所，叫伦敦神经反馈诊所。网址是LondonNeurofeedbackClinic.com。它位于东伦敦。B-Medic.com网站上也有一个名录，你可以在那里找到世界各地的反馈从业者。所以如果你不在伦敦，也许可以看看他们。他们不仅做ILF，还会做频段训练。
So that will be my next training, I think, is some frequency band training. Amazing. Thank you so much for your time in speaking with us. Thank you for having me on and talking about this is so exciting. Yeah. I'm excited too. Thank you, Madeline. Thank you so much for being here as a listener, as a watcher. If you've listened this far and you're not already following the show, wherever you listen to your MP3 podcasts, why not do me a little favour? and click follow. And likewise on YouTube, if you're not already a subscriber, please do. Consider
所以我想我的下一次培训将是频段训练。太棒了。非常感谢你抽出时间与我们交谈。谢谢你邀请我，谈论这个话题太令人兴奋了。是的，我也很兴奋。谢谢你，马德琳。非常感谢作为听众和观众的你。如果你听到了这里，并且还没有关注这个节目，无论你在哪里收听MP3播客，为什么不帮我一个小忙，点击关注呢？同样在YouTube上，如果你还没有订阅，请考虑
subscribing and clicking that notification bell so that you never miss another episode. I definitely believe that our bandwidth can be affected by all sorts of things and grief is a big one. If you are grieving or you know somebody who is that absolutely can diminish our capacity, I think you might well find the Grief Collective book really helpful. If you've enjoyed this, episode and you'd like to learn a little bit more about the history of traumatic brain injuries. There's a really great episode on Phineas Gage and what that taught us as a profession about traumatic brain injury. That's on screen for you now or linked in the show notes. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
订阅并点击那个通知铃铛，这样你就永远不会错过下一集。我坚信我们的带宽会受到各种因素的影响，而悲伤是一个很大的因素。如果你正在经历悲伤，或者你认识正在经历悲伤的人，这绝对会削弱我们的能力，我想你可能会发现《悲伤集体》这本书非常有帮助。如果你喜欢这一集，并且想多了解一点创伤性脑损伤的历史。有一集关于菲尼亚斯·盖奇的精彩节目，它教会了我们作为专业人士关于创伤性脑损伤的知识。它现在就在屏幕上，或者在节目说明中链接。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。